All right, let's get started.
So today we're going to discuss subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
And I think the best way to motivate
this is to start with an example.
So let's start with uh
a very simple example
of a game. Let's draw it like this.
The story is that we have two players
and the first player can choose whether
to exit or enter, let's say some market.
We can think of them as firms. If they
exit, then both players just get a
payoff of zero.
But if they enter
then the other firm two can choose
whether to accommodate this new entrant
or to fight.
Right? So
if player one enters, player two chooses
accommodate or fight. If they
accommodate the new entrant, that's good
for both players. They both get one. If
they fight against the new entrant,
that's bad for both players. They both
get negative one.
So
first let's just represent this in
strategic form. This is a bit of a
review here. Um
So if we represent this in strategic
form, player one has two strategies, N
and X.
And player two has two strategies, A and
F. And we can put them here. And then we
just need to fill in the payoffs.
Well, if player one does not enter, if
they exit, then both players get a
payoff of zero. So we have 0 0 0 0.
If player one enters, then it depends
what player two does. And if player one
accommodates, we get 1 1. And if player
one fights, we get -1 -1.
So now as usual, let's try to solve for
the Nash equilibria of this game.
And I'll say given if player
two play accommodates, then I'm better
off entering.
If player two fights, then I'm better
off exiting. And then if we do it the
other way
we're going to get this.
So here we see that we get two Nash
equilibria.
Namely, our two Nash equilibria are
N A
and
X F.
So what's the story here?
One Nash equilibrium is player one
enters anticipating that player two is
going to accommodate their entry.
The other Nash equilibrium is X F.
Player two Player one exits. They don't
enter because they anticipate that
player two will fight.
And both of these are Nash equilibria.
Both players are playing optimally given
the way the other player is behaving.
But we argued last week that in games
like this, one of these is more
compelling than the other. Do you find a
problem with any Does any of these Nash
equilibria involve a non-credible threat
that might maybe makes it less
compelling than the other Nash
equilibrium?
Yeah. Is the player two will fight in
both that and X F case?
Right. So this is a Nash equilibrium,
but this involves a non-credible threat.
Why? Well, in this equilibrium, player
one is exiting. They're choosing not to
enter because they anticipate that
player two will fight them.
But that's not a credible threat. If
they actually were to enter
then player two would find it optimal to
accommodate, not to fight.
So this
uh second Nash equilibrium
it involves a non-credible threat. And
if we want to be a little more formal
about it, this is going to violate
backward induction.
We can easily apply backward induction
to this game. We start with player two.
They'd rather accommodate than fight.
And given that player two is going to
accommodate, player one would rather
enter.
And indeed, backward induction
gives us the other Nash equilibria of N
A.
So this is kind of a review of what
we've done before. This is a game of
perfect information. We were able to
apply backward induction and that was
able to identify one Nash equilibrium as
being uh compelling prediction in the
game and the other Nash equilibrium as
being less compelling because it
involved a non-credible threat and more
formally, it violated backward
induction.
But now let's modify this example
slightly.
Let's suppose that now
player one chooses
exit or enter as before.
It's 0 0.
But now if player one chooses to enter,
then player one and player two will play
a simultaneous move game.
And we can represent that by saying,
well, player two is going to make a
move. They're going to choose, say,
accommodate or fight. But then player
one is also making a move.
So we'll put these in the same
information set.
And we'll say player one chooses, I
think
uh top or bottom. This
So just so we understand
what's going on here. Now as before,
player one first chooses whether to exit
or enter the market.
But if they enter the market, then
player one and player two play a
simultaneous move game.
Where player two chooses between
accommodate and fight.
And player one chooses between the
interpretation that's so important, but
T and B.
And notice here that I've written this
as if player two moves before player
one.
But whenever we have a simultaneous
simultaneous moves and we want to
capture that in the extensive form, the
way that we do that is we can
arbitrarily pick a sequence and then
just assume that player one does not
observe player two's move. So if we had
switched the order here and said player
one moves and then player two moves not
having observed what player one did,
that would be equivalent to player two
moving first and then player one moving
not having observed what player two did.
So now let me just fill in the payoffs
here.
Uh make sure I
get this right.
So we're going to have
2 2
-1 -1.
No.
2 2 1 1.
Make sure I get this right.
And then
fight T.
Great. So as before, accommodating is
good for everyone. Fighting is bad for
everyone. But now player one's choice
between T and B can sort of affect the
intensity of that good or bad for the
two players.
Okay.
So now let's go through our same
analysis as before. Let's represent this
in strategic form and let's solve for
the Nash equilibria of this game.
So now player one has
four strategies, right? Because player
one chooses N or X and then they also
choose T or B.
Notice player one here only has one
information set. If these were in
separate information sets, then player
one would have to move at three
information sets. But here we just have
one information set and another
information set. So for player one, the
strategies are
N T
N B
Uh maybe I'll write it this way. Yeah,
sure. This way doesn't matter. X T X B.
And the strategies for player two are
just A
and F.
And now we need to fill in the payoffs
of this matrix. Well, let's do it
systematically.
If player one exits, then we know that
no matter what player two or player one
subsequently does
uh
we're going to get 0 0.
So here we're going to have 0 0 0 0
0 0 0 0.
Because in all of these strategies,
player one first exits and that's just
ends the game with a payoff of 0 0.
Next, let's figure out what happens
under the other two strategies or the
other four strategies.
So first, player one enters.
If player two accommodates
and player one plays T, then we're going
to get 2 2.
And if player two accommodates and
player one plays B, we're going to get 1
1.
And then if we do it over here
we're going to get
I did that right? Yeah. So all I've done
is filled in the paths in this matrix.
Okay?
So now let's go through our standard
procedure and let's try to find the Nash
equilibria of this game now that we have
it in strategic form.
We're going to say if player one is
going to accommodate, then player two
finds it optimal to do this.
If player
two is going to fight, then player one
finds each of these optimal.
And now we're going to go row by row. If
player one is playing NT, then player
two would like to accommodate. For an
NB, then we're here. For here,
So now we get three Nash equilibria.
Let's write these down.
We get
NT
A.
We get
XT
F.
XB.
All right.
So here,
player one enters the market
anticipating that player two is going to
accommodate.
And then they follow this up by playing
T.
In both of these equilibria, player one
exits the market because they anticipate
that player two is going to fight, and
then it doesn't actually matter. They
could do T or B and we have an
equilibrium either way.
But now let's ask the same question as
before. Do any of these equilibria seem
more compelling to you than
any others?
Does Does any of the Do any of these
involve kind of non-credible threats?
Any thoughts?
Yes.
Right. So
these two
seem to involve non-credible threats,
right? Why? Well,
player two is fighting when player one
enters,
but fighting just makes both players
worse off. So we don't think that if
player one actually enters, player two
is going to be willing to follow through
and fight.
So intuitively,
these involve non-credible threats.
But formally, we can't apply backward
induction to this game.
Why can we not apply backward induction?
Yeah?
It's not a game of perfect information.
So the issue here is
conceptually, we think that we'd like to
select this equilibrium because we think
that these equilibria are bad for the
same reasons as in our first example up
here because they involve a threat that
will not actually be optimal for the
player to carry out.
However, we don't have the formal
methodology to rule out these Nash
equilibria because our existing
techniques of backward induction don't
apply to games of this form because this
game does not have perfect information.
So the problem here
is that backward induction, BI,
does not apply
because this game does not have perfect
information.
Maybe we'll say it's because this game
has imperfect information.
What is the imperfect information here?
It's that when player one moves down
here, player one has not observed what
player two's action is here. So they
don't have perfect information about the
previous moves.
And indeed, that makes it difficult to
apply backward induction because when we
tried to apply backward induction,
we wanted to say, well, how should a
player move at each of these nodes? But
if you're at an information set with two
with multiple nodes in the information
set, it's not clear how to carry out
this procedure.
So
the plan for today
is to introduce a new solution concept
of SPNE, which I wrote up here, subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium, that is going
to capture, so we'll say this in words,
it will capture the idea
of
credibility,
but it will apply to a larger class of
games than backward induction did.
But it
to a larger class of games.
Namely, it will
apply to games that have imperfect
information.
And also, it will allow for infinite
games.
That is games where we keep making moves
over and over again and there's no clear
end point. Remember we argued last week
when we looked at negotiation that there
was kind of this artificial aspect to
our model of negotiation that there was
some time at which the world ended and
there couldn't be any negotiation beyond
that point. We had to impose that
artificial deadline because we didn't
have the tools to analyze games that
could potentially go on forever.
And now with subgame perfection, we'll
be able to do this.
I want to be clear here. Of course, it
also applies to games of perfect
information and finite games, but in
addition to infinite games, it applies
to games of imperfect information and
infinite games. So maybe I'll say also.
Of course, it it also applies wherever
backward induction applies.
And maybe the last thing I'll say is it
extends
backward induction. What do I mean by
that?
Whenever backward induction does apply,
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium will
give us the same answer.
So
i.e.,
it agrees
with backward induction whenever
backward induction applies.
So we had this class of games where we
could apply backward induction. Subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium is going to
give us the same answers on those nice
games, but it's also going to give us a
compelling answer in other games beyond
that class. And that's uh what we're
hoping to do today.
Okay, well let's try to understand
what went wrong. What was non-credible
about this?
And I'd encourage you, one way to think
of this,
well, we have the term subgame in the
name subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
We're going to think of subgames, that
is smaller games that are part of the
larger game.
And notice that once we get to this
node,
we can think of the rest of this
as a game in itself, as kind of a
smaller subgame within the larger game.
And if we think of this as a smaller
subgame,
the
payoffs in this smaller subgame
are actually going to look
basically
like these.
So we can think of this smaller subgame
as, well, player two is choosing between
A and F.
And player one is choosing between just
T and B, so we can kind of ignore the N.
And we can compute what the payoffs are
for each of those pairs of actions or
strategies in this subgame.
And
we can see that
only our combination of
Let's kind of look at this subgame.
So
in this equilibrium that we found
compelling,
in the subgame, player one plays T and
player two plays A.
And we can see that in this subgame, if
we look at it as a single game, this
will actually be a Nash equilibrium of
the subgame.
But if we look at how people play in the
subgame in any of these strategies, TF
or BF,
these will not actually be Nash
equilibria of the subgame.
Um
and that's going to be kind of
conceptually what violates our notion of
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium. So let
me um
try to be a little more
precise about this.
So what we can do,
so let's
sort of apply subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium to this example. I said we
can represent this as kind of its own
subgame, but let's be a little more
formal about this. We can think of this
as we have player one. They're choosing
whether to exit or enter.
And if they enter, we now have a
subgame, which is a simultaneous move
game, and we can just sort of think of
it as a block like this.
>> And indeed, we get 2 2
-2 -2.
So, this is not technically an extensive
form game. This is kind of a heuristic
derivation, but we can think of what's
going on as after player one chooses
whether to exit or enter uh the game,
then we play this simultaneous move
game.
And what we would expect and what we'd
like is that
in this simultaneous move game, the
players are actually playing a Nash
equilibrium.
So, we can work within this simultaneous
move game and figure out what are the
Nash equilibria of this subgame.
Well, we apply our standard procedure.
We just underline things.
And we see that only
this
is a Nash equilibrium.
So, we see that
TA
is the only one.
So, if we believe that once player one
enters,
from thereafter, the two players will
play a Nash equilibrium in that subgame,
then the only possibility is that
thereafter they play TA.
And anticipating that they're going to
play TA, it's optimal for player one to
enter.
And now we've exactly replicated our
compelling equilibrium over here.
So, next I want to
describe this procedure more formally,
but are there any questions about the
example and how we've done this so far?
introduction
Okay.
So, what I argued is that in this big
extensive form game,
we could treat a subset of this game as
a game in itself.
And And we call that a subgame.
And that's what we want to do. So, the
first step is to defining subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium is we first
need to define subgames
of an extensive form game G.
And the intuition is, you know,
intuitively it's clear. What we want is
we want to look at subsets of the tree
that would constitute games by
themselves if we thought of them uh
separately all by themselves.
So,
what a subgame is going to consist of
is it's going to consist of
a initial so, a node
and all its successors.
So, what does that mean?
Let's take this as an example.
I start here at a node
and I include every node that comes
after this. So, that's this node, this
node, all the way to the terminal nodes,
this node, this node, this node, this
node.
Right?
But, we have to have certain conditions.
The
initial node
has to be in its own information set.
Maybe I'll emphasize.
So, we have a single
Maybe I'll call this the initial node to
give it
uh context. So, we pick some node, which
will be our initial node, and then we
include all successors, all nodes that
come after that node. But, then we have
two requirements.
Our first requirement is that the
initial node
is in a singleton information set.
AND THIS IS JUST TO TO ENSURE THAT
THIS INITIAL node and everything that
comes after it
would constitute a game in its own
right. Remember when we defined an
extensive form game, one requirement of
extensive form game is that it starts
with an initial node and that initial
node is by itself in its own information
set.
So, if we want this node to serve as the
initial node of our subgame, it better
be a singleton information set.
And then the second requirement is that
the subgame
doesn't break
information sets.
Let's say what this means in words.
Breaking an information What I mean by
that is I take a node and all of its
successor nodes. I kind of draw a box or
curve around all these nodes, and I need
to make sure that there's no information
set that includes nodes in this game and
also nodes outside the game.
That would be what I mean breaking the
information set.
And under these conditions, we indeed
have a subgame.
So, let's note one observation.
The entire game
is one is a particular subgame.
How can we see this? Why is the entire
game necessarily a subgame?
What do we choose as our
initial node for this subgame?
We just choose the initial node of the
game, right? If we take the initial node
of the game
and then all its successors, that's just
going to be every node in the game. And
then we have to check are our two
conditions satisfied? Well, that initial
node better be in a singleton
information set because that's part of
the definition of an extensive form
game.
And it can't break information sets cuz
where else could they go? We're
including every node in the game.
So, let's go back up here
and see which nodes can start a subgame.
Okay? So, I'll start here.
Can this node
start a subgame?
Yes, right? This is what we said. If we
start here and look at everything after
it, this gives us a subgame.
And this is precisely the entire game.
Uh and maybe
when I say initial node, let me say
non-terminal node because I realize
we'll get some
So, what about this node? Well, I guess
we could think of this as a subgame if
we wanted, but there's nothing to do
once we're here cuz we're already at a
terminal node. So, we're not going to
call that a subgame and that's why we're
going to say this is we have to start at
a non-terminal node.
What about this node? Can this node
start a subgame?
Yes, right? This is the subgame we
already looked at. We start at this
node. We look at everything that comes
after it.
And we checked that our conditions are
satisfied. Is this initial node in a
singleton information set? Yes.
And do we break any information sets?
Well, the only non-singleton information
set we have to worry about breaking is
this one and we see that it's not
broken. So, we're good.
What about here? Does this constitute a
subgame starting at this node?
And why not?
It breaks some info set.
It breaks info set. Actually, it
violates both of our conditions, right?
It It And generally, these can be
intertwined. It's going to break an
information set and also it's not in a
singleton information set. So, it
actually violates both.
And then the same is true here. If we
tried to start uh a subgame here, we'd
run into problems because this initial
node is not in a singleton uh
information set and we would also break
this information set.
Okay.
So, this is how we define subgames. And
notice, if you're looking for subgames
in a of a game,
because every subgame starts with a
non-terminal node, the way you can look
for them is just go through each
non-terminal node and say, "Can this
non-terminal node start a subgame?"
So, start there.
If we wanted to start a subgame, we're
going to have to include every node that
comes after it. And then we just check,
if we do that, do we satisfy these two
conditions?
So, this is how we identify subgames.
And now that we understand what a
subgame is, we can define what subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium is.
So, here we'll
give our definition.
So, here
we're given an extensive form game.
So, let's say we're given
an extensive form
game G.
Remember, Nash equilibrium could be
applied to a strategic form game.
Subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
requires us to look at the structure of
the extensive form. So, we have to be
given an extensive form game here, not a
strategic form game.
And we're given an extensive form game,
we say that a strategy profile
S star
So, what we're interested in is a
strategy profile in G. Let's remember
what a strategy profile is.
It specifies a strategy for every
player.
And remember, in an extensive form game,
what is a strategy? Do you remember what
is a strategy in an extensive form game?
Well, it's uh yeah.
Exactly. It's a function or a vector
that says for every information set,
what action or move do we take at that
information set. So, I'm not going to
include that on the board here, but just
keep in mind that's what a strategy is
in an extensive form game.
is a
Maybe I'll just write SPNE.
So, subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
if
Well, intuitively, what do we want?
We want to look at every subgame of our
game,
and then we want to look at our strategy
profile within that subgame, and we want
to check that that would constitute a
Nash equilibrium within that subgame.
Right? So, let's say if for every
subgame
G prime of G.
So, I'm going to impose a requirement on
every subgame, and we've already gone
through how we can identify all our
subgames by looking at all the nodes.
For every subgame G prime of G,
well, we sort of want to say that
S star is a Nash equilibrium of the
subgame. Right? So, at first you might
be tempted to say S star
is a Nash equilibrium
of G prime.
And that's basically what we want to
say, but there's an issue here.
If S star is supposed to be a Nash
equilibrium of G prime,
well, the problem is that then that S
star must be a strategy profile in G
prime,
but S star is not a strategy profile
that necessarily in G prime, it's a
strategy profile in G.
So, S star tells us how what we do at
information sets that may not be in the
subgame.
So, we just have to be a little more
careful and say, well, let's look here.
I think we all know what we mean.
We want the play specified by the
strategy profile to be a Nash
equilibrium down here, but of course we
can ignore what's done up here because
this is not part of that subgame.
So, I'll use the notation
maybe S star
restricted to G prime,
and this is just I don't want to really
go through formally the definition
because I think it just makes it seem
harder than it is, but we only look at
the parts of the strategies that are
relevant inside the subgame. So, we
might call this the restriction
of S star
to G prime. And remember, since we said
a strategy specifies a move at every
information set, here we're only going
to keep track of the moves at
information sets that are contained in G
prime.
Uh
Again, if you, you know, this is a
graduate game theory class, we get
really formal about introducing notation
for all these things and what it means,
but I I think it's pretty clear
conceptually
uh what these things mean.
So, first question.
If we have a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium, do we know it's a Nash
equilibrium?
So,
if we have a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium, does that imply that
something is a Nash equilibrium? So,
give me a strategy profile. Suppose I
know it's a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium,
do I know that it's necessarily a Nash
equilibrium? And maybe a better way
instead of the implication, let's just
draw do this graphically. So, what we
want to say is is it the case
that the set of SPNE is a subset of the
set of Nash equilibrium?
So, we'd like that to be true. We'd like
just like when we came over here, we
said there's a lot of Nash equilibria,
and we wanted the subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium to be a special one of those
Nash equilibria. So, indeed, we'd like
Of course, they could agree, but we want
to make sure that every subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium The point is we want it
to be a Nash equilibrium and satisfy
these stronger assumptions. So, it
should be a Nash equilibrium. How can we
see that this is a Nash equilibrium from
the definition?
So, this doesn't require
it's, you know, you have to see it, but
it's not a long argument. It's pretty
simple. Yeah? G is a subgame of G.
Right. So, why is this true? Well,
G prime G is a subgame.
So, let's look at our definition.
Our definition says for every subgame,
this statement holds.
So, in particular, it holds for the
special subgame G prime equals G.
So, if we plug that in, it says the
restriction of S star to G
is a Nash equilibrium of G.
But what is the restriction of the
strategy profile to G? It's just the
strategy profile itself, because G is
the entire game.
So, this is stronger than Nash
equilibrium, but it it implies Nash
equilibrium.
Uh okay.
Let's uh maybe go through some examples
to see how we would approach this.
Uh let me
come down here.
Uh any questions before I go to the
examples?
Okay, so let's do one more example, and
this is going to be
um
like our a variant of our Boston game.
Where first
we're going to have player one,
and they can choose, maybe again I'll
call it entering and exiting.
And if they exit, we'll say we both
players get 1.5.
So, we're going to think of exiting,
well, this is just really to illustrate
the concept, but this means we're not
really going to uh we're going to do
some alternative activity rather than
the Red Sox or the Celtics game.
But then if they enter, then we're going
to play. This is like they say they're
sick and they just stay home.
Uh so, now we're going to have, let's
say, player two is going to move
to Celtics or Red Sox,
and then player one,
not observing what player two does, is
going to choose Celtics or Red Sox.
And we're going to follow our convention
that I think player one prefers Celtics
to Red Sox, so we're going to have 2 1,
1 2,
0 0.
So, now let's try to compute
the SPNE of this game.
Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> So, what's our Here's kind of a a recipe
for solving SPNE. Step one is always
identify the subgames.
So, the So, how many subgames
does this game have?
Can we identify the subgames? So, let's
go through.
Starting here with is definitely a
subgame, because the entire game is
always a subgame.
This doesn't start a subgame because
this is a terminal node, so we can't
start here.
This node will start a subgame, because
if we go here and everything below it,
then we have a single node by itself,
and we're not going to break any
information sets if we
go like that. So, that looks good.
What about this node here? Does this
start a a subgame? No, because this is
not a singleton, and then similarly down
here, this is not a singleton. So, it
actually is exactly the same structure
as this game over here. We're So, in
this case, we're going to have two
subgames.
And then a good approach, step two,
is to work backwards, just like we did
with backward induction. So, we want to
start with the smallest subgames and try
to solve for an equilibrium within that
subgame, and then kind of build up
backwards. So, step two is going to be
let's work backwards.
So, let's see how that works.
Well,
here working backwards is pretty easy,
because there's only two subgames, so we
certainly know where to start. If we
want to work backwards, we want to start
with this subgame, right? So, let's look
at this subgame,
and let's represent this in
strategic form.
So, we have
Celtics, Red Sox, Celtics, Red Sox.
Player one is choosing between Celtics
and Red Sox. Player two is choosing
between Celtics and Red Sox, and we know
the payoffs are just like the Boston
game we studied before.
Okay?
So, this subgame of the larger game
reduces to a very simple simultaneous
move game that we can think of in
strategic form that we've already
analyzed.
So, what are the Nash equilibria of this
game? Let's look at pure. We could also
talk about mixed strategies, but let's
focus on pure strategies for now.
It's the game we've already analyzed.
Yeah? CC and RR. Great. So, we have two
Nash equilibria. We have CC and RR,
right?
So, notice this is actually a a pretty
important difference with uh backward
induction applied to perfect information
games. When we did backward induction to
perfect information games, most of the
time we didn't have ties. We didn't have
multiple uh solutions, because at each
point a single player was making a move,
and generally one move was better than
the other, and we just selected that.
But here, when we're working backwards,
we're working at the level of an entire
subgame, and we know that generally
games can have many equilibria.
So, when we work backwards, what we're
going to do if we wanted to find all of
the Nash equilibria that are subgame
we'd actually need to make a choice
here.
We need to first try this and then work
backwards and see what happens and then
try this and work backwards and see what
happens and in the end we may find
multiple subgame perfect Nash
equilibria. So, by working backwards, we
start at our smallest subgame,
we choose
a Nash equilibrium of that subgame and
then we work backwards and then we have
to do it all over again with a different
choice. So, you can see eventually this
could get pretty complicated. So, let's
first make choice one.
So, here we have two choices, right?
So, the first choice would be CC
and the second choice would be RR in
this subgame.
Okay.
Well, now let's start with our first
choice, CC, and we'll do kind of what we
did in backward induction is we'll treat
this subgame as if once we reach this
subgame, this is what happens. So, let's
highlight CC is going to take us
down here.
So, now let's move a step back and look
at the choice for player one.
So, player one anticipating that if we
get to this subgame,
CC is going to be played
and therefore the payoff is going to be
2 1,
does player one want to exit or enter?
They want to enter, right?
So, now when you make choice one and we
work backwards, we see that player one
wants to enter.
And now we have one subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium,
but we have to be careful to write it
down.
Let's see, what is player one's full
strategy? Well, player one is going to
enter here
and they're going to choose C down here.
So, remember at the end we want a
strategy profile, so our strategy
profile
is going to be this.
Right? We have to list how player one is
going to behave at every contingency. At
this contingency, they're going to
enter.
At this contingency, they are going to
play C and I actually I should have
highlighted this as well
even though it doesn't affect payoffs.
Remember,
if
player one is choosing C, then they're
choosing C, they have to make the same
choice at every node of their
information set. So, I I should have
highlighted this. Let me make that
clear.
Um so, player one chooses N here, they
choose C at this information set. So, we
get NC is the strategy for player one
and then for player two we just get C.
Now, let's go through the same procedure
making a different choice of our
equilibrium in this subgame.
Okay.
So, now our choice is RR.
I I don't want to mess up and I'd have
to redraw the graph, so it's going to be
too hard to erase, so let's just do it
in our heads. If If we choose RR, then
upon reaching this subgame, we go RR,
the payoff is going to be 1 2.
So, now when we take a step back and we
look at player one, what is optimal for
player one?
Yeah.
They want to exit, right? Because 1.5 is
a higher payoff than 1 2. So, now when I
go back, I'm going to get exit and now
if I put it all together, what is the
complete contingent plan for player one?
It's exit at this node and
play R at this point, right?
Now,
so great, in this game we found two
subgame perfect Nash equilibria,
but
there could be some other Nash
equilibria that aren't subgame perfect.
Uh
can anyone see
an example of a Nash equilibrium that's
not going to be subgame perfect? Maybe
it's a
bit tricky, but let's just look at this
here. Let's focus on this
uh subgame perfect Nash equilibrium,
right?
We know
that
if player one exits,
we might say, "Well, if they're going to
exit, it doesn't really matter what they
do down here."
So, you might be tempted to say, "Let's
Let's look at a different strategy
profile, say
XC
uh
R."
And let's check if this is going to be a
Nash equilibrium and if it's going to be
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium. So,
we don't think it's going to be a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium because
it didn't get spit out of this
procedure, but let's see if it's going
to be a Nash equilibrium.
Given that player one
is playing XC as their strategy pro as
their strategy, can player one can
player two do any better than choosing
R?
So, does player two have a profitable
deviation from this strategy?
Why? Why not?
Thoughts here? Yeah.
Right. I mean, they have a complete
contingent plan, but if player one is
playing X, then we're definitely going
to end up here whatever player two does.
So, if player two were to deviate, the
payoff would be exactly the same.
And that means that any deviation by
player two will not be profitable.
No deviation is profitable, so player
two does not have a profitable
deviation.
What about player one? Does player one
have a profitable deviation?
Any thoughts? Yeah.
The no and let's let's see why that is.
So, we have to be pretty careful here.
If player two is playing R,
well, by exiting I'm getting a payoff of
1.5. Could I ever do better?
Well, I could enter and then play C.
So, if I enter, player two plays R and
then I play C, I get 0 0.
That's definitely worse, but I think I
have a better deviation.
What is my better deviation going to be?
Yeah.
Yeah, so in fact, instead of XC, I think
my best deviation is going to be NR. So,
instead of doing X, I'm going to enter
and then because I believe that player
two is going to go to the Red Sox game,
I also want to go to the Red Sox game
and that gives me a payoff of one.
But that's still worse than my payoff of
1.5. So, indeed, this is a Nash
equilibrium,
but not a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium.
So, if we go to our circle over here,
this lies somewhere in here, right? It's
a Nash equilibrium, but it's not a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium. We
already checked that it's a Nash
equilibrium or at least verbally, we
said neither player can profitably
deviate from this strategy profile and
that implies that it's a Nash
equilibrium.
We argued it shouldn't be a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium because it
didn't come out of our procedure, but
let's formally check what's violated
about this
uh
strategy profile. Why does this strategy
profile not satisfy our definition of
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium?
So, what's wrong? It is a Nash
equilibrium, but it's not subgame
perfect.
And why is that?
Thoughts?
Well,
what's let's look at our subgame, right?
In our subgame,
player one is playing C and player two
is playing R
in our subgame here
and that means player one is playing C,
player two is playing R, we're at 0 0
over here.
This is not a Nash equilibrium of the
subgame
because in this subgame,
in fact, either player could deviate. If
player two changes to R,
they would get
a higher payoff because then they would
player one would get one.
And similarly, player two could deviate
to C and they would get a higher payoff.
But we have to be really careful here,
right? I just said that it is a Nash
equilibrium and neither player can
profitably deviate
and now I'm saying in the subgame, a
player can profitably deviate. So,
what's what's going on here?
So, it is a Nash equilibrium, no one has
a profitable deviation in the entire
game,
but I'm saying
in the subgame down here, there are
profitable deviations the players have
and that's why it violates the
definition of subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium.
So, what's going on?
So, what's going on is there are
profitable deviations in subgames that
are not reached.
Right?
So, why?
Uh
maybe I'll make the more general point.
When we're at a point here, what's going
on?
How can we have a strategy profile
that's a Nash equilibrium, but not a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium? What
must be the case is that there must be a
profitable deviation
and we have to be precise about what
that means. Profitable deviation within
the subgame
that is not reached.
And this is exactly the idea of a
non-credible threat, right? It says
if we were to get to this subgame, if we
were to get to this node,
some player could do strictly better.
That's why we're vio That's why the
strategy profile violates subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
But it doesn't violate Nash equilibrium
because under the strategy profile, we
don't actually get to this subgame.
So the fact that I could do better if
this subgame were reached doesn't mean I
could do better because when I change my
play here, I'm not actually affecting
our final payoff because we're going to
get stuck over here.
Um so it's exactly what we talked about
with backward induction. Remember we
said Nash equilibrium does not require
optimal play at unreached contingencies.
Similarly, Nash equilibrium does not
necessarily require Nash equilibrium
play in unreached subgames.
So we're just kind of replacing
contingencies with subgames.
And indeed, there may be a profitable
deviation at a subgame that is not
reached, but that doesn't mean there's a
profitable deviation within the entire
game.
I think that's kind of a subtle point
and that's the heart of subgame
perfection. Uh any questions about that?
If not, we'll move to a more substantive
example.
Good.
All right.
So now
let's go over here.
And now we're going to consider an
application where we can apply subgame
perfection to try to make a prediction
about behavior in this game.
So this is going to be
uh Cournot competition
with entry costs.
So we're going to look at classic
Cournot competition. Remember Cournot
competition is quantity competition. So
each firm chooses how much quantity to
bring to market and then the total
quantity brought to market determines
the market price and then each firm
sells their quantity at that market
price.
And
we're going to make start with
everything exactly as before. So we have
N firms.
We have constant marginal cost C.
Remember this is the constant marginal
cost of production.
And then we're going to specify the same
convenient demand that we usually
specify, which is
P of Q.
If quantity Q is brought to market, what
is the market price going to be? Well,
intuitively, the market price should get
smaller the more that's brought to
market, right? And we're going to use
the same specification,
the maximum of 1 minus Q and 0. Exactly
what we said before. So if more than one
unit is brought to market, the price is
just zero.
And if almost nothing is brought if
nothing is brought to market, the price
is one and then we sort of interpolate
between between that linearly.
Uh but now the key difference
is that
the firms can't just produce, you know,
immediately. They have to choose whether
they want to enter this industry.
So, you know, if I want to
be if I can't just, you know, produce
corn at my farm today, I have to first
buy a farm and start entering the market
and decide that I'm going to become a
farmer, right? So uh in this example,
the firms each firm has to first make a
choice about whether they want to
participate in this industry, whether
they want to say pay the upfront costs
that would allow them to produce. So in
in your econ course, you probably heard
the difference between fixed costs and
marginal costs. Here C is playing the
role of marginal costs. This is a per
unit cost I pay to produce, but I also
have something like a fixed cost. I have
to buy a factory to start producing or
buy a farm to start producing. So this
game is going to proceed in two stages.
In stage one,
each firm simultaneously chooses whether
to enter the market. In other words, pay
the upfront cost to be a player in the
market. So each firm
simultaneously
chooses
whether to enter.
And entering has a cost.
I'll say at cost, well,
we'd like to say C, but we already have
C here, right? So I'll say at cost F.
You can think of this as a fee or as a
fixed cost, right? This is building a
factory, buying a farm.
And then stage two,
the firms who've entered each choose how
much to produce.
Uh maybe I'll say the present firms,
that is the firms who've entered,
choose quantities.
And again, this is simultaneous.
So first each firm chooses
whether to enter at some cost F.
Some subset of the firms has entered.
And then the present, this is not great
grammar, but I just mean the firms that
are present, the entered firms, uh
choose simultaneously the quantities to
produce and then we just play the
Cournot game.
Something's I would say here though, we
have to be really careful. I think I've
there's one detail I haven't specified.
There's something I need to specify as
part of the game.
What What have I not told you that's
important?
So we have the players, we have the
actions, we have the payoffs, but
information.
So we have to be clear here, what do
these firms in stage two know?
Do they know who else has entered?
That's an important consideration in the
way we model the game. We're going to
assume that they do observe this. So
So I'll say the set of
firms that enter is observed.
Or maybe I'll just say entering is
observed.
So if you want to start a factory, you
want to buy a farm, people observe that.
People see that you're now in the market
and that's potentially going to affect
the way they behave in the second stage,
right? And this is crucial. If you were
a firm and you were deciding how much to
produce, part of your market research
would exactly be to see what other firms
are present in the market, right? And is
there a new entrant? That may change how
much you want to produce. So we're going
to assume that this market research has
been done and that this entrance
decision is publicly observable.
Okay.
So now we'd like to
solve for a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium of this game.
So let's
solve for SPNE.
And let's follow our procedure. Step
one,
identify all the subgames.
So any thoughts? What is going to be
What are going to be the subgames
of
this game? Well, certainly the entire
game is a subgame.
So first let's find the subgames.
Well, we have kind of the entire game.
That's always easy. That's what happens
at the beginning of stage one.
But then there's going to be a lot of
subgames in stage two.
All right. So in stage two,
what's going to start a subgame? A
subgame can only start at a history
that's observed by the players. That's
another way of saying when we say that
the initial node must be in its own
information set, think of that as saying
we're a subgame can start at a history
if everyone knows we're at that history
when we're at it. There can't be any
uncertainty about which history we're
at. So what is
observed? Well, here, what is the
history at stage two? Well, what we know
at stage two is which firms have entered
and which firms haven't.
And in fact, each of those histories
will start a different subgame.
So in fact, the subgames are going to be
parameterized by the set of firms who
entered.
I don't have to specify who didn't enter
because that's just everyone else,
right? Once I know who entered, I know
who didn't enter.
So we have and this is in stage one,
and then we have a subgame parameterized
by
I'm going to say parameterized.
That just means
we can describe the subgame by this
quantity. Maybe I'll call it I subset
of 1 through N.
And the interpretation of this is this
is the set of players who entered.
And I guess maybe if you want to be
really formal,
let's say it's not an empty subset.
Because if no one enters, then we're
actually at a terminal node because no
one has any decisions to make, so that's
not going to start a subgame.
So maybe I'll just write it like this.
So we have Sorry, this is math notation.
All it means is we have some non-empty
subset of firms who've entered. We all
observe that. And then based upon that,
we all decide how to play. Of course,
remember if if this is the set of firms
who've entered, this is also the set of
firms who have a choice to make in the
next period. The other firms aren't even
present. They don't even matter in this
subgame, right? Uh so
sometimes a subgame might involve only a
subset of players.
And that's happening here. Only these
players are going to be involved in this
subgame.
Because if you don't enter, you have no
choice to make.
Okay.
So now
let's try to work backwards and try to
solve this.
So step two is working backwards.
So, I I've achieved step one. I've
identified the subgames.
Now, I want to work backwards. So, I'm
going to start with the subgames here
and try to find a Nash equilibrium of
each of these subgames.
So, suppose we're in stage two.
And suppose that the set of firms that
has entered is I.
So,
let's say we're given
non-empty subset.
So, I'm saying suppose we're at the
contingency where this is the set of
firms who've entered.
That defines a subgame.
And now I need to try to solve for a
Nash equilibrium of this subgame. Okay?
So,
I'm going to think, well, what are
the sub strategies in this subgame,
right? Remember, we just need to think,
what are the decisions that need to be
made within this subgame?
Well, what we need is each player
firm
I in I,
the other firms don't have any decisions
to make, right? It's only the firms
who've entered. Each firm I in I is
going to choose a quantity QI to
produce, right?
So, these are the sub strategies within
this subgame. Once I'm in this subgame,
each player I who's involved just needs
to choose some quantity, and I think we
just said this is just some non-negative
quantity, right?
So, now we'd like to solve for
a Nash equilibrium of this subgame.
Do we know what to do here? Does this
fit in with something we've studied
previously?
Any thoughts?
Well, this subgame is just the classical
Cournot competition game we studied, but
with a possibly smaller set of firms.
So, we've already we already know how to
analyze the subgame because the subgame
reduces to something we've already
studied. So, this is just standard
Cournot
with well,
effectively, we only have as many firms
as have entered, right? So, we need some
notation for that. I'll say uh
What this means is if I have a set I,
this means the number of elements of
that set. So, this is just counting how
many firms have entered.
So, with this many firms.
And we know how to solve that.
Notice one thing that all that matters
for the Cournot outcome is the number of
firms.
So, even if a different set of firms has
entered, each entering firm is going to
produce the amount that each firm who's
entered will produce depends only on the
number of firms who have entered, not
the identities of the firms. But that's
because of our assumption that the firms
are all symmetric, right? If one firm
could produce at a lower marginal cost
than another firm, then we'd have to
keep track of the identities of the
firms. But since all the firms are ex
ante equivalent, ex ante identical, we
don't really care who's entered, we just
care how many people have entered.
And what is the solution of this? Does
anyone
recall what is
QI star
going to be? Does anyone remember?
This is I think for tests a good
kind of thing to know.
Um
well, we have 1 - C on the top because
the more costly it is to produce, the
less each firm produces.
And on the bottom, well, the more firms
there are, the less we produce.
We know a monopolist produces 1 - C over
2.
So, if we expand that uh formula
or that pattern, we're going to get the
number of firms plus one.
So, if
I am the only firm,
so the number the cardinality of I is
one, then I as the only firm am a
monopolist and I choose 1 - C over 2.
If there's two firms, we each produce 1
- C over 3. If there's three firms, we
each produce 1 - C over 4, and so on.
Um
Now, notice, let's think back to how we
approached this problem before. We
looked at the subgame.
We found a Nash equilibrium of the
subgame, but then the key step was to
compute the payoffs in that Nash
equilibrium because the payoffs in that
Nash equilibrium determine the choices
that the players are going to make
higher up in the tree.
So, this is what will actually be done,
but let's compute what the payoffs will
actually be.
So,
how do we compute payoffs? Well, my
payoff depends on how much I produce and
also what the market price is. So, let's
now compute the market price.
So,
the market price is
a function of
the total amount produced.
Each of the firms is producing this
amount, but there's
uh
I of those firms. The total amount
produced is going to be
I over
I plus one
times
1 minus C.
Do you see how we got this, right?
Each firm is producing 1 minus C over I
plus one.
But there's I firms altogether, so when
we add it all up, this is the total
amount produced.
And now, what is the formula for P?
Uh
It's actually
maybe a a a cleaner way of doing it is
we don't really just care about C P, we
care about P minus C, right? Because
this is going to be
the profit per unit that each firm gets.
Because each firm is producing this
amount.
This is going to be the market price.
This is the cost per unit. So, the
difference is going to be the profit per
unit. And here we get a nice algebra
simplification, right? Because we get
P is 1 minus Q. So, we're going to get 1
minus this minus C.
But that's 1 minus C minus some fraction
of 1 minus C.
So, we're just going to get the residual
fraction of 1 minus C.
And we're exactly going to get 1 minus C
over this.
You see how this happens? It's we get
all of 1 minus C minus the fraction I
over I plus one of 1 minus C.
So, what's 1 minus I over I plus one?
It's just 1 over I plus one. I can go
over it if that's tricky, we can go over
it again, but
any questions on that?
No?
Okay.
And this also makes sense. My profit per
unit is decreasing in my cost
and also decreasing in the number of
firms who have entered.
So, now what we can write down
is
we can actually compute So, this is a
good I think thing to remember. What
we're computing is the per
firm
Cournot profit.
And it's a bit messy to keep writing
cardinality of I. So, let's say with K
firms.
So, what I'm going to say is if we're
playing a Cournot game and there's K
firms altogether,
what is each firm going to get in
equilibrium?
Well, it's going to be
So, I'll call this pi K star.
And it's going to be the amount produced
by each firm
times the profit per unit.
So, this is going to be
well, I'll just use this formula, 1
minus C over K plus one.
Notice, it's exactly the same. I've just
changed notation because I don't want to
keep writing uh writing this.
And then I'm going to multiply that by
the profit per unit, which is exactly
this. Again, I'll use my K.
And well, it actually is a pretty simple
formula that
uh
I think this is kind of a good formula
to memorize for exams. I mean, you can
always rederive it, but I think that's
kind of a a nice thing to keep in mind.
Let's make sure we see what we're doing
here. The first term is the quantity.
The second term is the
profit
per unit.
And it turns out that these are exactly
the same.
Why are they the same? Well, this goes
back to your maximizing area of a
rectangle subject to a perimeter, and
you always want it to be a square, but
that doesn't really matter. This is what
you get.
Okay.
So, now we can kind of understand
if K firms enter, what's going to
happen.
If K firms enter and we play a Nash
equilibrium of that subgame,
then the K entering firms will each
produce this amount. They'll each get
this profit per unit, and they'll each
get this total profit.
And now we can move
to stage one.
So, let's go here.
So, now let's move back to stage one.
So, we've actually simultaneously solved
it. At first, this seemed really hard.
We had a huge array of subgames to deal
with, but we actually gave one general
formula that works for any single any
subgame. Whatever subgame you give me, I
just compute how many firms have
entered.
That becomes my K, and now I've computed
uh the Nash equilibrium of that subgame.
So, I've actually covered every subgame
at once.
And now we need to move to stage one.
So,
the question at stage one is
an entry decision. So, now each firm
chooses maybe
enter and X, enter or exit.
Exit it, you know, a better term would
be enter or not enter, but
yeah, enter and exit is is cleaner to
say.
Well, now
this becomes a bit tricky, right?
Because
let's look at each firm's decision
problem.
If they exit,
that is, if they don't enter at all,
what is their payoff going to be?
Just zero, right?
If they enter, and then after entering,
everyone plays a Nash equilibrium,
what is their payoff going to be?
Well, this is tricky, right? Because it
depends on how many other firms enter.
So, we have a formula for their payoff,
but it's going to depend on the total
number of firms who enter.
So, it's going to be
pi K star,
which equals
1 - C over K + 1 squared, if the total
number of firms who enter
is K.
Which means if K minus one other firms
also enter.
Right?
So, if K minus one firms also enter,
well, when I enter, that makes K,
and therefore, this is going to be my
payoff.
This is
I think if you just stare at this, it
starts getting hard cuz you got to
figure out the K. The K determines the
enter, it gets hard. So, I think the
best way to do it is to say,
can we find an equilibrium where K firms
enter?
Okay?
So, let's look
for an equilibrium.
And if there's an equilibrium where K
firms enter, it's not actually going to
matter which K. Then there'll be an
equilibrium for any subset with of size
K because all the firms are the same.
But there may not This may not exist.
So, let's try to think
if there's an equilibrium in which K
firms enter,
what must be true?
It means each of the firms that entered
finds it optimal to enter,
and each of the firms that doesn't enter
finds it optimal not to enter.
So, I guess the question is, does any
firm have a profitable deviation
at stage one?
So, let's look for profitable
deviations. Let's consider a firm
that entered.
Uh, what did I use? N?
So, let's consider this deviation. Let's
look at a single firm that did enter.
So, here K firms, let's assume K is at
least one.
Let's look at a firm that entered and
consider what would happen if they
deviated and and exited.
Well, this firm is entering.
So, what is their payoff
from entering? This is their payoff in
equilibrium.
Their payoff is
well, what?
So, let's take the perspective of one of
the K firms who has entered, and they're
saying, what is my payoff going to be in
this game?
Well, I enter,
K firms in total enter, so my payoff is
pi K star from entering, but I have to
pay this cost this fee F.
And sorry, I missed that part. minus F.
Right?
Because if I enter, I get this in that
subgame, but I also have to pay the fee
for entering. Otherwise, this would be a
pretty easy problem.
Okay?
So, if I
So, this is what I get in equilibrium.
What if I exit?
Well, then I get zero.
Right?
So, what we need
is each of these firms that entered is
willing to enter because this is greater
than equal to this. Right?
But now you might say, wait a second, if
each of these firms found it optimal to
enter,
doesn't that mean we're going to have a
deviation cuz isn't one of the firms
that didn't enter also going to want to
enter?
So, now it seems like we're stuck,
right? We have to make sure that the
firms that entered actually find it
optimal to enter,
but if they find it optimal to enter,
why doesn't one of the other firms that
didn't enter deviate and enter as well?
Well, let's go through their problem,
right? Let's look at a firm that didn't
enter
and consider their deviation.
So, if they didn't enter,
they're getting a payoff of zero, right?
What if one of these firms
And you know, the arrows may not
Hopefully, what I'm saying verbally
makes it clear what these arrows mean,
and you might want to take notes on
this.
So, if I'm one of the firms that didn't
enter, and I deviate now, and I enter,
what is my payoff going to be?
Yeah? Pi K + 1 star minus F. Exactly,
and this is the key difference, right?
If I'm one of the firms who's entered,
there's only K minus one other firms
who've entered.
But if I'm one of the firms who hadn't
entered, now I face a different problem
because I face K other firms who've
entered, and this means that if I don't
enter, sorry, if I enter, I'll get pi
K + 1 star minus F.
Because there's already K other firms
who've entered. If I deviate and enter
as well, now there's K + 1 of us who've
entered,
and I need this also to be unprofitable.
So, I need this.
So, what is my condition for this
equilibrium?
Well, F has to be small enough so that
the firms that enter find it optimal to
do so,
but large enough so that the firms that
don't enter find it optimal to not
enter.
And what we need is pi K + 1 star
is
less than or equal to F
is less than or equal to pi K star.
And indeed,
these pi stars are decreasing in K.
Let's look at our formula.
This is definitely decreasing in K.
So, this makes sense.
This inequality says, if I'm one of the
firms that did enter, and I'm getting pi
K star, it was worth it for me to enter
because what I'm getting is better than
the fee I had to pay to enter.
But this is saying, well, if I'm one of
the firms that didn't enter, if I
contemplate deviating and entering, I'm
only going to get this much, and that
can't be worth it for me because F is
higher.
So, let's just draw a little graph to
finish.
So, what I want to do is I want to plot
all these kind of pi K's on this chart.
So,
we're going to get
uh, something like
pi one star,
pi two star, it's quadratic, so they're
going to start getting close together,
pi three star,
pi four star, let's
pi N star.
So, we can plot all these points on the
graph.
And we can try to see what's going to
happen based on where F is relative to
these points. Okay? So, given the demand
parameters, I can draw
I can graph each of these numbers all
the way up to N cuz N is the total
number of firms.
And let's first say what happens We have
to be a little careful if F is exactly
at a boundary. Let's not worry about
that. Let's say what happens if F is
here.
How many firms enter?
Here, no firms enter
because this says the entry cost is
higher than monopoly profits.
So, the only equilibrium is no one
enters.
That's an equilibrium because if I were
to enter and deviate, then I would get
monopoly profits, but that's not enough
to offset my fixed cost.
So, if F is here, we see zero firms
enter.
So, here I want to keep track of how
many enter.
>> [snorts]
>> What if the cost is here?
Now, how many are going to enter?
One, right? This satisfies my equation
here with K equals one, right? There's a
There's an equilibrium with one firm
entering if F is between pi two star and
pi one. That's exactly my formula here.
So, we get that one enter.
And now we can keep going.
Down to here, two are going to enter.
We're going to keep going.
And I guess the tricky thing is what
happens if F is
here.
If F is smaller than pi N star,
then actually all N are going to enter,
and even if F gets all the way down to
zero, there's no more firms than N that
can enter, right? So, we can't continue
this pattern indefinitely because
there's only N firms. The most that can
happen is they all enter.
Uh,
okay?
So, here we've used subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium as a solution concept. We've
gotten a unique prediction in the game,
and we've actually, I think,
delivered kind of a nice qualitative
industrial organization insight, which
says industries that have large fixed
costs
will tend to have fewer firms in them.
And industries that have very small
fixed costs will tend to have more more
firms in them. And this is exactly what
we see, right? We see We tend to see
monopolies in industries like cell phone
networks, utilities, where you have to
pay this huge fixed cost to create your
your network, but once you create that
fixed cost, the marginal cost is pretty
low. What's going on here? Well, if F is
up here, it's worth it for, say the
monopoly utility provider to enter the
market, but it's not worth it for anyone
else to enter because if they were to
enter, they would only sorry, I should
be here.
Let's say fixed costs are here. It was
worth it for the first utility company
to enter because they're getting
monopoly profits that's higher than the
fixed cost. But if a second firm
contemplates entering, they're going to
have to pay this fixed cost F, but
they're only going to get these profits
pi two star because they're going to
have duopoly competition with the other
firm and it won't be worth it for them.
So the simple model delivered, I think,
a pretty robust prediction about the
organization of of industries. I guess
one question I'll leave you with though
is suppose we have n firms
and our equilibrium says k strictly less
than n should enter.
That's our equilibrium. K of them enter
and minus k don't, right? Well, which k?
How do How do they coordinate on which k
of them enter?
Uh and I think that's kind of a puzzle
that maybe this model can't really
explain.
You know,
um
I'd like to be one of the firms that
enters, but
you know, if too many of us enter, it's
not an equilibrium. So how do we How do
we coordinate on this? Do we mix? Do we
flip a coin to decide whether to enter?
Is there something missing from the
model? Things to think about, uh but
I'll see everyone on Thursday.